do you think there's intelligent alien
civilizations out there
that our bots might meet
my
hunch is no
most people say yes absolutely i mean in
the universe
too big and they'll cite the drake
equation
and and i think in uh singularity is
near
um
i have two analyses of the drake
equation
both with very reasonable assumptions
and one gives you
thousands of
advanced civilizations in each galaxy
and another one gives you one
civilization
and we know of one
a lot of the analyses
are forgetting the exponential growth of
of computation
because we've gone
from where the fastest way i could send
a message to somebody was with a pony
which was what like uh a century and a
half ago yeah
uh to
the advanced civilization we have today
and and if you accept what i've said
go forward a few decades you can have
absolutely fantastic amount of
civilization compared to a pony and
that's in a couple hundred years
yeah the speed and the scale of
information transfer is just
is growing exponentially
in a blink of an eye
now think about these other
civilizations
they're going to be spread out at cosmic
times
so if something is like ahead of us or
behind us it could be ahead of us or
behind us by
maybe millions of years which isn't that
much i mean the
the
world is
billions of years old
14 billion or something
so
even a thousand years
if two or three hundred years is enough
to go from a pony to fantastic amount of
civilization
we would see that
so of other civilizations that have
occurred
okay some might be hot behind us
but some might be ahead of us
if they're ahead of us they're ahead of
us by
thousands millions of years and they
would be so far beyond us they would be
doing galaxy-wide engineering yeah
but we don't see anything doing galaxy
web engineering
so either they don't exist
or this very universe
is a construction of an alien species
we're living inside a video game
well that's another explanation that yes
you've got some teenage kids in another
civilization
you